christophe robin est agriculteur depuis
2012 à la ferme de la une hier suite au
départ en retraite de ses parents en
il prend les rênes de cette exploitation
c'est un éleveur passionné j'ai pris
l'habitude de prévenir les volailles
quand même quand on arrive dans le
bâtiment c'est éviter de le stress aussi
à la ferme de la hunière des poulets
fermiers sont produits dans ce bâtiment
d'élevage 600 volailles sont présentes
dans ce 80 mètres carrés
on a pourrait organiser l'espace et
l'ensemble des bâtiments donc la
prochaine étape ça va être de mettre une
porte dans le fond ici dans le pignon
qui sera automatisé dans son
exploitation à son chant christophe
robin fabrique l'aliment des volailles
avec les céréales de la ferme et on
cultivateurs jeu produit à la fois du
blé et du maïs que c'est la base de
l'aliment des volailles cet agriculteur
prend soin de ses volailles qui sont
bien en chair alors les amis ça va là
dedans avec une durée d'élevage entre 90
et 120 jours
la semaine prochaine je vais en emmener
un petit peu au salon de l'agriculture
pour fournir le stand hagrid map
l'époque vivent là on avait dû 3 qui
l'occupera kg ou vif
christophe robin fait partie de ce
mouvement qui rassemble plusieurs
exploitants afin de lutter notamment
contre la grille bashing une certaine
méfiance à l'égard du monde agricole
il va falloir continuer à nourrir une
population qui est grandissante
satisfaire les besoins
en bien-être animal et en production de
qualité et de proximité il faut réussir
à faire revenir les gens à la ferme
qu'ils aient quitté en visu ce qu'on
fait pour avoir un lien avec ses
consommateurs l'agriculteur se rend au
marché de clairefontaine en yvelines
christophe et damien met en place les
produits de la ferme de la lumière c'est
8 90 le prix attention je t'ai c'est la
plaquette
si tu as un but sur quoi que ce soit tu
prends la plaquette l'éleveur maîtrise
90% de la production de la filière
seules les parties abattage et des
coupes sont délégués les consommateurs
ont pu déguster les produits de la ferme
et parfois repartir avec ceux des nôtres
que vous voulez
christophe robin sera présent mercredi
26 février sur le stand à grille demain
du salon de l'agriculture s'est produit
aussi aller au bout dimanche à rome